ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi
siamo su infiniti e deprimenti ragazzi
c'è questo cervo che deve attraversare
la strada
ovviamente le macchine vanno a finire
oltre i confini del mondo dove c'è anche
capitan sparrow è una roba che al
successo saranno caduto nei confini del
mondo merda e va beh ragazzi a il gioco
più bello che abbia mai fatto in tutta
la mia vita non sospiri non so che altro
dire sono estasiato cioè sono morto
dieci secondi di gioco
ho già pagato tutto record che ci sono i
conigli che cos'è una roba che ti pare
attraversare
no no ma star the bastard e vabbè
comunque ragazzi devo il mio scopo è
quello di attraversa la strada senza
essere schiacciato senza che mi vogliano
i conigli
porca [ __ ] come mi sono salvato lì non
mi fate domande cosa fa era ma da il
nostro facendo niente stanno bocciando
tutti a caso ma è che [ __ ]
ma chi è che mi ha dato la patente a voi
topo gigio era ifix sono riuscita a
arrivare dall'altra parte della strada
che è l'obiettivo del gioco è il secondo
obiettivo è quello di oltre a non far
morire i conigli e quello di far
bocciare il più possibile le macchine
perché guadagni punti credono tipo se
faccio così sì ma non mi ammazzati con i
piccoli addio mio penso fossero morti
meno male venite con me venite con me
che vi porta in salvo vite attenti
attenti un'andata un andato veloce
veloce
dovete morire tutti dovete morire tomica
che incornato dato stamattina è la cosa
più [ __ ] che la cosa io abbia mai
giocato negli ultimi dieci anni almeno
ma che roba che cazzo è ma che dice è la
madonna
ho fatto un casino rega mi dispiace non
era mia intenzione giuro però va beh
intanto andiamo avanti fatto un disastro
che abbandona il cane in autostrada
apparirà un cervo con tanto di incidente
quindi non fate queste cagate è una roba
che o mio dio
robe piazza è successo è sceso pure
arcangelo gabriele a darmi la
benedizione dopo sa cosmi era attento
attento a dove vai madonna mia kit ha
dato la patente ma l'hai mai visto un
cervo per strada è così che si tratta di
cervi che attraversa la strada ma dimmi
te ma guarda che è stronzo
i ragazzi a parte tutta la vita se
riesco a fa sta roba decentemente veloce
cosa ho schivato dove vai
probabilmente ragazzi era una donna che
si era accorta di aver dimenticato il
trucca casa è per tornare indietro ha
fatto caso
comunque a parte questo uscire
attraversa bravo dove la cap
eccolo eccolo perfetto madonna ma chi
mentasti giochi stati passa per il
cervello a chi inventa sta roba voglio
capirlo voglio voglio scoprire queste
cose antiquari come la madonna che
autostrada è ci passa un aereo
porca [ __ ] veloce dove dov'è il buco
dov'è il buco fatica l'apocalisse oh mio
dio succedono robbie che mi ha salvato
il culo sto camion veloce va bè
incornato incornata bravo corri corri
cervo corrie si è addio disastro che sta
lasciando il gesù fa un po mi esplode il
computer ragazza non facendo più
incidenti guai era niente sta finendo il
mondo rega mio dio no toschi madonna che
lag ma chiama papà cena 6 madonna che
incide una ragazza è bellissimo pra vivo
adesso voglio 10 stato e non si capisce
un cazzo sono laghi della madonna ne
siano anche a muovermi ma vi rendete
conto il disastro così ora che rompa mio
dio
e vabbè neverending parti e gli oro in
biden miliardo allagato come mai nella
vita giardino mi stava esplodendo la
casa non so come
è veloce veloce spin cervo di merda vai
vai nel buco nel buco ed è gol
ci sono vecchiette che attraversano la
strada ai conigli miei venite tesori uno
di voi lo chiama bob e l'altro chiama
charlie miei charlie vitus è quello più
bello da charlie charlie labbra odio
ciardi bravo da charlie bob senti stami
attaccato al culo perché io vi ammazzo
le famiglie a tutti le cozze sony coni
perché conigli ogni tanto non ci sono
più spariscono non si sa dove vanno a
finire
e vabbè però è togliti dalle pene allora
calmi con tanta calmetta mentale
calamità mentale quello che volete
prova a ri piano piano
ok perfetto no anche lui ha dimenticato
il trucco a casa è na roba allucinante
ho schivato corsa minchia ho schivato
medaglie ma proprio a fiumi le voglio
cena roba comunque la roba migliore di
tutto sto casino e quando fai quando fai
le schivate allucinanti che non sei
neanche tu come me ho fatto prima a fare
quella impressionante mi stava
esplodendo il pci mi sembra un incrocio
tra doc simulator è qualcosa da fare o
cazz quel gioco che dovevi fare
attraversa le rane mi ricorda ghazi
esiste il freno freno schiacciate il
frente il freno shumpert vai è roba ma
[ __ ] ok girano da brown era
bravissimo micai vinto sorprendermi la
valigia cosa c è dentro i deal di varici
a trottola è passato adesso la
precisione millimetrica ragazzi tra
queste c'era ancora il me stesso di
prima ha steso a terra ascolti e mi
scusi perché ecco saper caso dove il
messico da qualche parte ma proprio
bastardo sapevo neanche le indicazioni
rientrasse un cervo nei glutei proprio
perché roba va chi lo fa a roma e vivo
una borsa come dove dove hanno regalato
andato voglio seguirlo dov'è andato
spiegato per cos'è oddio questa esalta
come ho fatto a saltare calmi cosa
succede
macchine che volano cosa no no la
valigie mia stronzo noi capito accordo
ragazzi voglio provare a farne una
portando almeno anche bob e chardy
dall'altra parte se riesco a ragazzi
seguitemi però attaccati dove c'è stata
almeno charlie ha minacciati vieni
charlie viene bravo charlie però io non
so che non ho fatto la ceretta inutile
che mi guardi così seguimi piano
la fai una roba non seguirà merel oggi
però veloci no fermi fra bravo fermati
si è fermato anche lui e ragazzi stanno
diventando i miei idoli stanno trovando
il freno prima si era perso il freno nel
mondo piano piano che co2 conigli piano
piano cup singer
io li ammazzo ti ammazzo tutti dovete
morire dio santo
emma si bastardo
roba indecente la roba più impossibile
che abbia mai fatto nella mia vita
cagate mi quando vi dico seguitemi ok
perché se non ci arriveremo porca
[ __ ] porca norci veloci ragazzi
veloci veloci veloci veloci veloci
veloci grazie che girate sei morto da
solo vai vai vai ne manca uno ne manca
una che manca una no no no no sì sì
mostardi bike da dio mio ma bloccato la
strada che sono un passo sì sì sì sì o
addio
oh mio dio ciao ragazzi stati
impossibile non ci credo impossibile
insisto che è ma avete portato anche la
figlia da casa fatemi capiva ragazzi non
li e non son riuscito a portarne 2 per
un'ora e mezza come faccio a portarne 4
e nella base va beh come come il proverò
ma è bravo bravo sono persone un
fenomeno ave ragazzi così io per tutti
almeno è gratis che ha concluso che
l'episodio perché è stata roba più trash
che io abbia mai giocato dio mio sangue
ma che roba è una roba
io non lo capisco sto gioco ma roba se
no no no no no no è no è no
quindi ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
come al solito lasciato momento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come una
divisa trovate nella descrizione jose
vorresti discrete diavolo fosse una
bella ragazza